what was the bottom line on the whole
rosanna thing because you were at
executive producer the first year they
brought back Roseanne which I thought
you you had told me about it off the air
and you said to me a ham involved I'm
gonna bring Roseanne back and I went
that's a brilliant [ __ ] idea I think
it's great but then you quit right
I didn't people think you had a
falling-out with Roseanne but you didn't
or did you I don't even know it happened
I don't either
are you insane no we're not in touch and
on the whole thing's devastating I mean
I'm glad that they have been so
resilient and the Connors is on now
which a lot of people are asking if I'm
on I'm not but I watch it and Laurie
Metcalf and John Goodman and I'd you
know watch anything on Sara Gilbert so
[ __ ] good on it so I'm glad it's
still on and that they survived all this
but um but yeah I grew up watching Rosa
you know I mean so why did you leave
Rosa I left because it felt imminent
that there was an impending disaster
because of her tweeting yeah there was
it was it was getting progressively
worse and there was also a lot of tweets
from the past that I didn't know about
which is my fault
I didn't look through her old tweets I
guess there were some problematic tweets
from a couple years ago and I think
everyone was very like oh it's she's
admitted to being mentally ill this like
something happens I think when someone's
behavior is consistently like that where
you actually start to lower your bar for
their behavior you're kind of like oh no
that's just crazy Roseanne that's just
how it is and what my Roseanne was here
she was raving about you how good you
were in the writers room how good you
were at putting the shows together and
figuring out the plot lines and she said
it was just like unbelievable how good
you were at it yeah I put a lot of work
I mean a lot of us did I mean Norma
Connell was there and Wanda Sykes and
Morgan Murphy and all these great
writers they all leave to when this
whole thing went yeah Wanda
I mean Wanda left as soon as that tweet
came out I mean but I remember I was
trying to like I remember I pitched the
idea to make a fake Twitter app for her
where she thought she was tweeting yeah
oh that's great and she she between all
day like she's sort of nut but not yet
we wouldn't have to like put out fires
on three